all right so first of all I apologize
for this review being a week late I was
out of town and on top of that I thought
it came out in November the Puss in
Boots movie I remember seeing adds
months and months ago I said November so
uh I guess they changed the date or
maybe I just saw it wrong so my
apologies but I saw the movie so here's
what I thought this is put some boots
it's a spin-off of the Shrek movies and
I guess again when you talk about a
movie that's a sea horse spin-off you
have to say we thought the other ones
real fast
the first Shrek film I never got that
into I thought I had one or two good
jokes but didn't do that much for me but
it was decent it hated or anything uh
the second one I love I had Dora the
second well I thought the jokes were
much stronger the story was much better
characters more men more memorable one
of my favorite cavities third one didn't
like that I really fell flat and fourth
one didn't like but a few good moments
so really the only one I really enjoy
like really liked was the second I know
most people like the first one the most
but I'm a fan of the second one so now
we got puss and boots which again sort
of like the Pirates of the Caribbean
movies outsourcing for a whilst making
the sequel to do do spin off in this guy
this is the popular character you know
people who want to see a movie so they
they finally got to him a little too
late in my opinion but again same thing
with Jack Sparrow they began to be this
bit off movie earlier um but I digress
uh this movie it's practice just to go
in order of what the movie does not
necessarily what happens in the plot but
what the movie does uh the first 10 20
minutes is straight up comedy it's like
the Shrek films Jojo joke and they're
good they're very funny if you're a cat
person you're going to love this movie
because there are a ton of cats
especially in the first 20 minutes and
they're all cute they got the big eyes
and stuff so you'll love it
and then after that we sort of get into
this story that involves Zack get the
gig as humpty-dumpty just looking about
Humpty Dumpty and we get to this
backstory between em and puss and boots
friends and then we get his sidekick
which is like this female canned stuff
and they're off to look for the
Beanstalk or the magic beans to make
Jack and the Beanstalk
you know the Jack the Beanstalk story
come to life and it sort of go I don't
want say go serious but go straight-up
adventure around that point there are
still some jokes but it's not the focus
the focus is the adventure aspect it's
sort of like the pirate movies in that
sense that they're frozen sea more like
the jokes are there but it's more you
know not contact them all that stuff so
we have our hopes all that stuff um and
when they get to the castle to get to
the Giant's Castle and everything like
that all that stuff I swear these people
just wanted to make Jack and the
Beanstalk because it's great and the
ideas are great and the world looks
great it's Airy endless fear again it's
very pretty and it's very creative so
that stuff is all wonderful again mostly
hinging on adventure then we get to the
last third of the movie and I really do
not like the last third and actually
sort of anger to me it got very mean it
got very sort of a hate-filled and
usually I'd be okay with that because
it's like well hey if it matches to the
rest of the story it's great it's sort
of doesn't it comes out of left field
there's a twist with one of the
characters and it's one of those things
where now when you go back and you see
all the things that this one character
did you realize oh that that was false
that was alive at this really touching
moment that wasn't real and for a movie
like this I think you really got into
the touching moments and I think it
really angered me you when you find out
this twist but then on top of that after
that twist there's sort of another twist
where the character goes back to the way
that character was before and that
seemed out of nowhere
and everything having to do with this
twist I really didn't like and from that
point on it gets too serious I in my
opinion I think the climax doesn't make
a whole lot of sense it's not especially
create
of climax they're sort of building up
this monster that you're gonna see and
when you see it it's cute but it's not a
big lamp like this it's Stay Puft
Marshmallow Man and ghostbusters that's
a big laugh and they build it up and it
really delivers yeah and you get the
feeling they're trying to do something
like that I didn't feel really paid off
I didn't think it was strong enough um
and then sort of bands a source as
possible sequel maybe who knows
and yeah that's roughly about it so on
the whole it's hard to say whether or
not I guess I liked it because I like
the first two-thirds um but it's one of
those things where when you get to again
when you get to the last third it's like
oh but that that was not bad but nothing
you know you're not it's all you know
baloney you know and it's it's really
frustrating and I think that's gonna be
frustrating to a lot of people so that's
really bothersome but I get I'm glad I
saw you know they got some good the CG
is good I did see it in 3d it's good 3d
they don't do too many of this you know
but it still is enough that you're
impressed by it it's very bright it's
very colorful um there's a lot of stuff
kids will enjoy there's a lot of dancing
sequences are very creative and like I
said there's a lot of you know the
actual beanstalk world is very very
creative and very nice to look at I
would like to have seen the giant they
said they get in there it's like oh boy
we better watch out for the giant it's
like no don't you read the story he's
dead dude that's no fun think about what
you've done with the jacket that
would've been so much fun um but
whatever I mean that that's a nitpicking
um so I'm the hole I guess I enjoyed it
if you liked Puss in Boots if you liked
the Shrek movies you'll probably like it
if you're looking for a straight up
comedy you're not gonna get that much I
said the first 20 minutes you'll get
some and then just bits and pieces here
and there
um but it's mostly an adventure film
that's very important to keep in mind
so yeah I'm trying to think there's
anything else it it's hard to say
whether or not you like it depending on
if you like there's Shrek movies instead
if you like Puss in Boots if you do
every time you see on you you're gonna
love this fine you know and you
feel sorry for him when the bad stuff
happens you get to see him as a kitten
so of course you know everyone's got all
that stuff if you're looking for a
really really good comedy just fantastic
writing I don't get too much of it here
if you're looking for a good adventure
film it's decent
so yeah take that for what it's worth I
guess I'm glad I saw it like I said I
really didn't care for the last third it
sort of pissed me off but the rest of it
is a good movie and it's fun and it's
got you know a lot of the clever in
jokes with the happily ever after world
and stuff like that and the way they
build up they make these fairytale
sounds so serious you know have you
heard it the magic beats do not joke up
on magic beans I searched all my life
for magic beans
Sammy they they do a lot of bad in the
first 20 minutes so so I guess it's okay
it's decent in my opinion I'm glad I saw
it and hopefully you could serve gift
from this review whether or not you'd
enjoy it too if you're if you're really
looking for just the laughs or just the
adventure or you don't mind if there's a
twist in there that might change the way
you look at everything else um so yeah
there you go go check it out or don't
check it out and I shall talk to you
later